انخفاض دوره طائرات الحربيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بعد ان ظهرت بشكل كبير في
الايام الاولى للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه
وكذلك على الجانب الاخر تصاعد دور
الطائرات المسيره الهجوميه والانتريه
وايضا الصواريخ بعيده المدى كل هذه الامور
اثارت العديد من الاسئله حول دور الطائرات
الحربيه التقليديه في حروب اليوم وايضا في
حروب المستقبل وهل تراجع دور الطائرات
الحربيه مقارنه بالطائرات المسيره ام لا
هذا ما سنطرحه على الفريق المتقاعد ديفيد
تولا عميد معهد ماتشات الطيران والباحث في
استراتيجيات الحرب الجويه اولا جنرال
ديفيد اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا هل
تراجع دوري طائرات الحربيه التقليديه امام
الطائرات المسيره ولماذا لم نجد دورك كبير
للقوات الجويه سواء من الجانب الروسي او
الجانب الاوكراني بعد الايام الاولى من
الحرب
[موسيقى]
في هذا البرنامج الخلاصه الاولى التي
ينبغي استخلاصها من الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا اليوم هي ان التفوق الجوي يلعب
دورا اساسيا في تحقيق النجاح لانه يسمح
بحريه الحركه لتفادي الهجوم علاوه على
القدره على شانه ولم يتمكن حتى الان اي من
طرفي الحرب من تحقيقه هذا التفوق وهذا
الوضع اطال امد الحرب وحولها الى حرب
الاستنزاف وهو ما نتج عنه ارتفاعه اعداد
الضحايا وزياده حجم الدمار بشكل اكبر مما
كان سيحدث في حال اظهر اي من طرفيها تفوقا
في الجو وكما ذكرت فهناك طائرات مسيره
واستخدامها لتحقيق التفوق الجوي لكن ليس
لان الطائرات المقاتل التقليديه اقل قيمه
وانما نقص الكفاءه وسوء القياده والتدريب
والتجهيز الذي يبتسم به سلاح الجو الروسيه
وفي الوقت ذاته فان الاوكرانيين لديهم
سلاح جو صغير مقارنه بروسيا بالتالي فانه
في هذه المواجهه عجز فيها الجانبان عن
تحقيق التفوق في الجو واعتقد ان جوهر
سؤالك عن قدره الطائرات المسيره على تعويض
الطائرات الحربيه التقليديه
وجواب عن سؤالك هو كله لان المسيرات ما هي
الا اضافه للادوات التي يتم استخدامها من
اجل تحقيق اهداف المهمه المتمثله في
السيطره على الاجواء وتمكين القوات البريه
نتيجه لذلك من التحرك بحريه اكبر بغرض شن
الهجوم ما تستطيع ملاحظته هو ان
الاوكرانيين اظهروا مقدره كبيره على
استخدام سلاح الجو المتوفر لديهم الى جانب
انظمه الدفاع الجوي من اجل منع روسيا من
النفاذ الى مسافات بعيده في عمق الاراضي
الاخرانيه وهو ما جعل روسيا تعول اكثر على
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره التي حصلت
عليها من ايران للتعويض عن بقدرتها على
القيام بنشاط عسكري في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
الجنرال ديفيد الصواريخ بعيده المدى ظهر
لها حضور كبير كذلك في الحرب لكن هل تعتقد
اللجوء الى مثل هذه الاسلحه سيدفع بعض
الجيوش لاعاده ترتيب هياكلها الداخليه ام
لا
مره اخرى وبالنسبه للصواريخ بعيده المدى
فان لها دورا باستطاعتها القيام به في اي
نساء وهي احدى الادوات التي يستخدمها سلاح
الجو لبلوغ الاهداف الخاصه بمهمه ما لكنها
ليست متوفره بالاعداد الكافيه لاستبدالها
بالطائرات الحربيه التي بوسعها مهاجمه
الاهداف بشكل متكرر والعوده الى قواعدها
للتسلح وتوجيه ضربات من جديد ولو نظرت الى
الاهداف التي تتعرض للتهديد في اي صراع
عصري ستجد انها اكثر مما تستطيع اي دوله
ان تتعامل معه باستخدام اي فقط امم جنرال
ديفيد الان الكثير من الدول تعمل على
تطوير طائرات من الجيل السادس برايك ما هي
الطائره التي ستكون طائره نموذجيه بالشكل
الاكبر
ما نشاهده في هذه الحرب التي تدور روحها
بين روسيا واوكرانيا هو دليل اضافي يدفع
باتجاه السعي للحصول على طائرات من الجيل
الجديد ويبدو ان روسيا عمدت الى استخدام
الطائرات المقاتله من الجيل الرابع التي
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض لتجنب الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه من طراز 300 وهو ما يجعلها
عرضه للاصابه بصوارخ فعاله ضد اهداف على
ارتفاعات المنخفضه مثل صواريخ ستينجر اما
بالنسبه للطائرات من الجيل الرابع فهي
تمثل خطرا اكبر من حيث رصد هذه الطائرات
واعتراضها بصواريخ ارض جو تعود لحكمه
الحرب البارده لذلك ف قد فاتت تصاعب مهمه
رصدها وتحلق لفترات اطول وسترى بالتاكيد
المزيد من الاستثمارات تضخم الاجيال
المقبله من الطائرات الحربيه سواء كانت من
الجيل الخامس او السادس
الطيران والباحث في استراتيجيات الحرب
الجويه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التوضيحات